All right.
Anita Koumriqian, thank you so much
for joining me.
How are you?
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm doing well.
How are you?
I am fantastic as well.
Did I get the name right, first of all?
Anita Koumriqian, yes.
That's the American way
of saying that.
Wonderful.
And where are you from?
I was born in Iraq,
but I'm actually Armenian.
Okay. Wow.
So, we're talking right now
from the Alcorn offices, right?
Correct. Alcorn Immigration Law.
We're located
in Mountain View, California.
So, I got to speak
to quite a few lawyers through this show,
but this is going to be a special episode
because I'm going to learn
all about immigration law.
And specifically immigration law
in the context also of Silicon Valley,
which is hugely relevant
especially nowadays,
and I'd love to talk about
how it's impacted during covid.
How it's changed over, perhaps,
past the last decade or so.
And I'd love to hear also your story
about why you're working
in immigration law.
There's a lot of different places in law,
especially in Silicon Valley.
So, how about we get started.
Talk to me a little bit about your journey
and how you found yourself
working in immigration law.
Sure.
So as I mentioned earlier,
I'm an immigrant myself.
I was born in Iraq,
and my family moved over
to the United States in 1995.
My parents decided to make sure
that my two older sisters and I
could live an American dream
where we would leave a war ridden country
and come to the United States.
On the 20 year anniversary of us
being in the United States,
I graduated from law school
to really live that American dream.
So, growing up, I've always known
I wanted to do something to help people,
and when I was younger, it was always,
Oh, maybe I'll be a doctor,
maybe I'll do this, maybe I'll do that.
And it was about the seventh grade,
I was 12 years old,
I thought to myself,
I see so many of my family members,
so many of the people in my community kind of
struggle through the immigration field
of like, do we need a lawyer
Oh, I became a citizen,
I'm getting my green card,
all of this.
And I kind of told myself, my parents,
and I was super young,
so I really didn't know.
My parents came to the United States,
struggled to get us here today
so that we can live our American dream.
I'm gonna make my parents proud.
Go to school.
Educate myself as much as I can
so that I can help people
like my family when we first moved
to the United States.
So, finished school obviously.
I went to UCLA for undergrad,
Santa Clara Law for law school,
and joined the immigration field.
And that's what I'm passionate about.
I absolutely love it.
I have experience practicing
family law as well
so divorces and all of that.
And I'm glad that I've done it.
I'm glad I have it in my pocket
of experience and knowledge,
but I love immigration.
So, can you give me
a little bit of context
as to the immigration situation
in the United States?
I know that it's a very popular topic
of debate, especially in politics,
but I'd love to understand
a little bit better
what is the immigration situation
in the United States?
The United States is known as a country
that hosts a lot of immigrants
from all over the world.
This American dream.
I'm originally from Israel,
even though I was specifically born
in the US,
but a lot of my friends
are immigrants to the US.
So, talk to me a little bit
about what's happening.
So right now,
well, for the past four years,
it's been very, very up and down
immigration.
Everybody, for the longest time,
has built the concept
of the American dream.
We want to come to the United States
and join the melting pot.
And that's really transformed over time,
especially now as America becomes
less and less immigrant friendly
unfortunately.
But there's still hope.
That's what I tell people every day,
especially now.
There's still hope,
it just requires some creativity
of thinking outside of the box of
if we can't get you into the United States
with this type of visa
or this type of green card,
let's think how else we can work with you
to get you into the United States.
Every presidential candidacy
has their own agendas
in terms of immigration
and some are better than others.
And being in the immigration field,
you have to learn to go with the flow.
Every four years you have to adapt.
Every four years.
Sometimes eight years.
And yeah, you have to adapt.
You have to learn to, sometimes,
go with the punches
and swerve around them.
Since March specifically, and covid,
it's been especially difficult.
In my years of being
an immigration attorney,
there's never been such a volatile time
to be an immigration attorney
where I feel like every single day
we kind of have to keep our ears peeled to see
is there something new going on,
is there a new proclamation,
is there a new order,
what can we, what is going on that
we have to let our clients know about.
So, I feel like I've partially also
turned into a journalist
where we hear everything,
and then we try to put it in our own words
and send it out in a newsletter
to our clients and people in our network.
So for those watching,
before we dive deep into more of the work
of an immigration law,
can you explain a little bit better
why is there a controversy
in the democratic nation
of the United States,
a democracy,
and the American dream is something
that every person in the world, I think,
learns about when they think
of the United States.
What has been so controversial
about immigration
over the past several decades?
And why is it even an issue?
I mean it's an issue because,
in my opinion, it's a silly issue,
but it's the fear,
it's the protection of
American jobs, really.
It's the protection of our economy
of people coming to the United States,
whether it be legally or illegally,
and taking American jobs
which, in every immigration attorney's eyes
or every immigrant's eyes themselves,
is not really is not a thing.
I'm trying to stay as apolitical
as I possibly can during this.
Of course. Of course.
It's just out of fear
of protection of American jobs,
the American economy.
And I believe
that's what it really stems from.
So, with Democrats in office,
there's a different agenda.
There's a different mind frame
whereas when there is
conservative Republicans in office,
there's a different agenda
and a different mind frame.
And so that's the adaptability
that we're talking about.
And then, so, what is the privilege
that you have
as an immigration law attorney?
Is your primary job helping people
fulfill their goal
of coming into the US legally?
Absolutely.
So, what our goal is,
and what I always tell people,
at Alcorn Immigration Law,
what we focus on is helping individuals
come to the United States
to live their American dream
regardless of their geographic location,
their place of birth,
what their passport looks like.
We help individuals, employers,
employees immigrate here,
legally of course,
so that they can come here,
live here, stay here, work here.
And that's what we focus on.
Again, we do both
employment based immigration
as well as family based immigration
because while they're both
under the immigration law umbrella,
they're vastly different
types of immigration.
Right. So being in Silicon Valley,
what is the difference
between speaking to you
that you're based in Mountain View,
versus if I were to speak
to an immigration law attorney
let's say in Michigan or in Boston?
So, it really depends
on the immigration attorney
and the abilities that they have
to work remotely.
Right now, everybody is working remote.
But what we pride ourselves
on, being in the Silicon Valley, is that
we try to be as cutting edge as we can.
We have to work with,
and not necessarily compete with,
but keep up with the tech companies.
So, since the very start
or birth of Alcorn Immigration Law,
we have been fully remote.
We help people worldwide.
I've had clients
literally next door to our office
and I have clients in Brazil, Germany,
- Oh, wow
China, all around the world,
which makes my job so fun
because I get to work with people
worldwide.
And whether or not
they're local or not local
makes absolutely no difference to us.
We have adapted
to a fully remote environment.
But still, I'm assuming that
the majority of your practice
is people that want to relocate
to Silicon Valley?
I'm sorry. Yes.
So, most of the time
we practice specifically
inbound immigration.
We do not do out immigration.
So, it's people coming
to the Silicon Valley.
Most of the time it's the Silicon Valley.
Otherwise it's,
I'm moving to the United States,
I'm going to work
for an employer in Michigan,
and we can help them.
I'm going to come and join my spouse
who lives in Texas,
and we can help them.
Right. Is it really complicated?
Is it really complex getting authorization
to move to the US?
It is.
It's complex
in that there's always
so many different moving parts
and there's so many different hoops
that you have to jump through.
Whenever I'm talking to clients
or potential clients or anybody
about immigration, I always tell them,
What do you want to invest in? or
How do you want to invest?
Do you want to invest
your time, your energy,
your Google abilities to figure out
how to file this application,
how to get into the United States?
And you want to do it yourself?
Or do you just want to invest your money
and just have an immigration professional
do the work for you
so that you can put your head
down on a pillow and know they've got it,
they're taking care of me,
I don't have to worry about that.
So, I mean call me biased,
but if I were not an immigration attorney.
I mean, kind of like with my taxes.
I don't file my own taxes.
I do not trust myself.
I will convince myself
that I'm going to do something
where they're gonna come and say,
"Hey Anita, you're going to jail
because you didn't file your taxes."
Scary. Right.
And this is a life of decision.
This is a dramatic, dramatic thing.
Yes, absolutely.
It's vital to make sure
that you're doing it correctly.
So maybe in a high level,
without necessarily diving too deep,
If I'm coming now,
let's say I'm from Holland,
and I want to come to Silicon Valley
because I potentially want
to start a startup
and relocate to Palo Alto.
Or to Michigan,
which is also great tech hub.
What are some of the biggest steps
or biggest hurdles
that I might have to go through
until I become a US citizen?
So first, the first step, obviously,
is finding an employer
who will sponsor you
to come into the United States,
with either a temporary non-immigrant visa
or with an immigrant visa,
which is also known as a green card.
So they're two separate kind of things. There's visas-
What does that main sponsor?
I've heard this term quite a few times.
What does it mean for a company
to sponsor somebody?
So, in order for somebody
to enter the United States,
whether it's through
an employer employee relationship
or a family relationship,
you have to file an underlying petition
where somebody says,
"I'm a United States employer,
and I want that person in Armenia
to come and work for me.
I'm going to sponsor their employment
here in the United States.
So, they're going to come
and work for my company
and only my company
with this specific type of visa."
And there's so many
different types of visas.
On the flip side, I can say,
"I'm in the United States
and I want my spouse, my fiancee,
outside of the United States,
join me in the United States
so that we can live our life here.
I'm going to sponsor them here
to come into the United States."
So, it's that underlying petition,
that underlying sponsorship
that will allow somebody
to enter the United States.
So, it's less of a financial.
It's not a financial sponsorship.
It's more of a,
"I'm vouching that I'm the sole reason
of why they want to come here."
Right?
Correct.
There's also a financial sponsorship
aspect of it
depending on the type of status
that they're entering in on.
If it's family based status,
then the individual,
that petitioner, has to pledge
if this person enters the United States,
I'm gonna take care of them
financially.
If they obtain
any kind of public benefits,
food stamps, welfare,
anything from the government,
if they get that,
I will pay the US government back
because I'm their financial sponsor.
So, financial sponsorship
is different than petitioning somebody
to enter into the United States.
Okay. And has this industry
evolved over the past, I don't know,
decade or two decades?
So, I'm always curious
when I approach new industries
that I don't know, and especially law,
which in my mind, I'm still thinking back
I'm imagining a law school
and dusty shelves and people
are just like reading books
and arguing in court.
Has this industry
evolved, immigration law?
Kind of not really.
Immigration is pretty archaic.
There is the Immigration
and Nationality Act that was founded.
It's the law that find
or founded immigration.
It was years ago that that was founded,
so it's kind of archaic.
The laws, the rules in there are old.
I think immigration
needs a home makeover.
It needs a renovation.
But it's so hard to do.
Immigration laws change a lot.
Immigration laws change often.
And specifically with, more recently
in terms of financial sponsorship.
There's a new public charge rule
that was buffed up just recently
back in, it started in October of 2019.
Really started in February of 2020.
It's now off again,
and it's going to possibly
be turned on again.
It's the new idea of self sufficiency.
When an immigrant is coming
into the United States,
they need to declare,
Hey, I'm young.
I speak English. I have a degree.
I'm gonna come into the United States
and I'm employable, I can work.
I'm not going to be a public charge.
So, they need to declare
they're self sufficiency as well.
So while immigration is archaic,
does kind of need reform,
if you speak to any immigration attorney,
at the same time
they are trying to adapt
to the times as well.
So, it sounds like a lot
of the complexity here for immigration,
and I'm getting a better understanding
of this here, is that a lot of it
is ensuring that,
is looking at the economy,
that's a primary factor.
It's looking at how much the government
will have to provide for citizens
that may not be self-sustaining.
And then I guess, your role
as an immigration attorney professional,
is to bridge that gap
and to be able to help
whoever wants to fulfill
that American dream
to show that they're able
to meet those requirements
so that they can get
the authorization, right?
Yes, absolutely.
And that's where our job kicks.
That's what our requirement is
as immigration attorneys.
It's our job to be creative,
to make sure that we're on top
of all of the laws.
Ethically, we are required to do that.
As an attorney,
there's so many ethical obligations
that we have.
... making sure
that we stay up to date
with the laws and making sure
that clients do qualify that
and doing what we can to be creative
and nimble with everything as well
to get whoever wants to come
into the United States,
into the United States.
How long does this process take?
It must take years, right,
to get this done?
Not necessarily. It all depends
on the type of visa
or the type of green card
that you want to enter in on.
So, it can take anywhere
from a couple of months
to like two, three years,
all the way up to like 20 years.
So, it all depends on the type of visa,
who's petitioning for you,
and how you're getting
into the United States.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
And so, I'd love to hear a little bit
about your personal journey
with immigration law.
What part of it
do you really get excited about?
'cause obviously, you started law
not in immigration.
So you went to law school,
you go into family law,
and then you transition to immigration.
Have you always known
you'll end up in immigration?
Or is this something
that you stumbled upon and you said,
Oh, wow. I'm connected to this,
and this is something I'm curious about?
I've always known
that I wanted to do immigration.
When I first started working
in the immigration field,
I worked at a practice where we were doing
both family immigration,
family based immigration,
as well as family law.
I did more of the family based immigration
at that point,
but I would always beg,
"Hey, can I have
please have an immigration project?
Can I do this? Can I do that?"
And then I fully transitioned
over to immigration.
And now I'm a partner at the firm
that I work at,
and I absolutely love it.
And I wouldn't want to practice
any other field of law.
'cause for me,
immigration hits home
and I get to work with so many
different types of clients
all around the world.
And they are all
such a pleasure to work with
because they want to work with me
because they get something good from me.
They get a visa, they get a green card.
And it's fun and super rewarding.
As hard as it may be
to be an immigration attorney,
and sometimes I kind of feel like
the piñata of lawyers,
... so rewarding.
As a partner do you still do,
like what are the differences
and responsibilities
between being a partner at the firm,
being a paralegal.
I'm not really too versed
with how law firms work,
but just to paint a picture
of what your daily life looks like.
It all depends on the firm
and how they work, how they manage.
Partners oftentimes do more
of the higher end,
speaking to potential new clients,
doing more of the
business management aspect of it,
marketing.
But sometimes also do still get to do
pull up their sleeves
and actually get to work
on some legal work or at least mentor
to get some legal work done.
Whereas paralegals,
they're the ones,
they make the magic happen.
People underestimate paralegals
and how much they do.
So, I am so grateful for all of our
brilliant paralegals everywhere.
So, they are fantastic.
- I love it.
So, I know that I'm keeping you
one minute late
and I know you had a hard stop
that you have to run for a meeting,
but I have to ask you
the most important question,
and I'd love to understand a little bit better
about you through that, three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
And please elaborate a little bit
on these words and why those specifically
because I know you've put
a lot of thought into them.
Thanks.
So, one word I would say is passionate.
I am so passionate for what I do,
for the law that I practice
and the people that I help.
It's that passion that keeps me going.
Growing up,
I used to always hear people say,
"Anita, you have to find a job that
or a career that you love
so that you will never have to work
a day in your life."
It's going to be fun for you to do."
And I was like,
"That's not true."
There's no way that people
will actually want to work."
But it is.
So, if there's any young listeners
out there who are still trying to find
what their passion is in their career,
it is out there, look for it,
do not give up.
I'm empathetic.
I'm empathetic because I treat
every one of my clients
as if they're my own family members.
When I give my clients advice,
I look at them as if they're my mom,
my dad, my cousin, my sibling,
my best friend
because I know what it's like
to be in their shoes.
Being an immigrant is scary.
It's scary to be in those shoes
of really not knowing
what is going to happen with my fate
in this country
where I've worked so hard to get to.
So, you have to be empathetic.
You have to understand
why your clients are stressed out,
why they're anxious,
why their application
has to be filed today.
You have to get that.
And I'm hard working.
If I wasn't hard working,
I don't think I would be here today.
And it speaks for the approval rate
that I pride myself on having.
I try my best
on every single one of my cases,
and my passion and my empathy
all comes into it as well.
So, those are my three words.
I love it.
Anita, thank you so, so much.
This was wonderful.
I learned so much.
And I definitely hope
things will get better and easier,
especially for immigrants.
I can definitely testify
how wonderful of an experience
it's been for me
to have both my home country, Israel,
but also be in Silicon Valley
and in the United States in general.
And just recently
when there was the big announcement
that foreign students,
when it goes online,
they'll have to relocate
back to their country.
I was looking at a lot of my friends.
I was looking at my friends from Africa,
from the Middle East, from Europe,
and I was shocked.
And I saw all of a sudden
how things were falling apart
without their control
and it was very difficult,
so I definitely appreciate your work
very, very much.
Thank you for the insights
and stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
Wonderful.